the last place you'd want the Prime
Minister to be at a time of national
crisis for Boris Johnson this now a
deeply personal crisis to his
coronavirus symptoms worsen in tonight
he was moved into the intensive care
unit of London's st. Thomas's Hospital I
still have this is the last we saw of
him on Friday explaining on Twitter he
was still not in the clear a week after
his diagnosis taken to hospital last
night for tests and observation his
condition has continued to worsen in a
statement tonight a number-10
spokesperson said since Sunday evening
the Prime Minister has been under the
care of doctors at st. Thomas's Hospital
in London after being admitted with
persistent symptoms of coronavirus over
the course of this afternoon the
condition of the Prime Minister has
worsened and on the advice of his
medical team he has been moved to the
intensive care unit at the hospital the
PM has asked foreign secretary Dominic
Raab who is the first secretary of state
to deputize for him where necessary the
PM is receiving excellent care and
thanks all NHS staff for their hard work
and dedication just this afternoon
Dominic rod said the PM continued to
lead the government from his hospital
bed hours later he's taken on some of
those duties himself well the
government's business will continue and
the Prime Minister is in safe hands with
the brilliant team absent Thomas's
hospital and the focus of the government
will continue to be on making sure at
the Prime Minister's Direction all the
plans for making sure that we can defeat
coronavirus and pull the country through
this challenge will be taken forward are
you confident that the government is
under control tonight there's an
incredibly strong team spirit behind the
Prime Minister and making sure that we
get all of the plans that the Prime
Minister's instructed us to deliver to
get them implemented as soon as possible
and that's the way we will bring the
whole country through the ground of
coronavirus challenge that we face right
now the decision to move the Prime
Minister into intensive care was
something his colleagues his loved ones
his country
was hoping would never come to pass he
should be here and his absence could
have huge implications not just for the
Prime Minister and his loved ones but
for the rest of us too a virus that
doesn't discriminate a crisis deepening
by the day we now face the prospect of
navigating the worst of it without our
prime minister at the helm better ik b
stai news westminster